as with other first-person adventure
games like the seminal gone home
Firewatch isn't about combat or even
puzzles instead it's about atmosphere
and exploration both of an expansive
wyoming forest and a burgeoning
friendship the story follows Henry a
middle-aged fire lookout working near
Yellowstone National Park in the summer
of 1989 the painterly art style infused
the wilderness with a welcoming warmth
and the ever-present sounds of nature
make every moment spent in Firewatch
feel like all the best parts of a
real-life camping trip you spend the
vast majority of the game wandering
alone through fire watches dense
detailed forests but the game's real
focus rests on Henry's relationship with
his boss Delilah which manifests as an
extensive series of walkie-talkie
conversations with branching dialogue
options their humor and vulnerability
make both characters not only memorable
but sympathetic which makes shaping the
growth and evolution of their
relationship a truly unique joy
unfortunately the central mystery can't
quite match the quality of the
characters at first I got wrapped up in
the panic and paranoia but once I
learned the truth several story moments
simply didn't add up
it's a shame fire watch fails as a
mystery because it succeeds in so many
other ways its world is captivating its
design is clever and its characters are
beautifully human
[Music]